it was horrible it's very scary thing
it's like the old saying goes accidents
happen making a movie can be quite
dangerous in fact it's become
increasingly common for the actors and
actresses to accidentally injure
themselves on the set of their big
projects there's been times where these
injuries have caused the entire
production to halt while in other cases
it wasn't much of a big deal you had an
accident doing a stunt that's what
happens when you get overconfident
leticia wright has won over the hearts
of fans as t'challa's younger sister
shuri since she first appeared in black
panther and she has an even bigger role
in the sequel wakanda forever while
filming a stunt in boston on the set of
the sequel wright suffered several minor
injuries and was hospitalized thankfully
wright was out of the hospital within a
day and the production didn't need to
come to a halt oh whoa okay
jennifer lawrence had to channel her
inner katniss while filming the highly
successful hunger games films while
filming the second film catching fire
lawrence had ear infections from all the
diving and water scenes in the film
furthermore a jet from the film's
cornucopia scene punctured her eardrum i
went deaf in one ear for months but that
wasn't actually physically challenging
it was just ear challenging
jacob allordy suffered a concussion
while filming a scene in the season one
finale of euphoria while filming the
scene where his character nate gets into
a physical fight with his father things
got so intense that he repeatedly hit
his head on the hardwood floor which
caused a concussion it didn't seem to
bother lordy too much as he went on to
say that the scene was the most
fulfilling thing he ever shot
dylan o'brien suffered a serious injury
while filming the third and final maze
runner movie the death cure while
performing a stunt in a harness on top
of a moving vehicle o'brien was thrust
off the vehicle unexpectedly and was
then hit by another vehicle o'brien
suffered a concussion facial fracture
and laceration from the incident and
filming was postponed indefinitely
because of the severity of o'brien's
injuries along with scheduling
production wasn't able to start back up
again until an entire year later the
state that you're in after something
like that you just want to run from all
that stuff i didn't really even want to
leave my couch necessarily when i was
allowed to so yeah it was a big step
doing that we came back you know all got
together again a year later it was like
we never left
while filming the season one finale of
the hit show riverdale archie himself kj
appa ended up breaking his hand while
punching through ice to save cheryl oppa
admits that he got a little too excited
while filming the scene though oppa
wasn't really punching ice but instead a
foam mat that was on top of the ice oppa
didn't even feel it initially and it
wasn't until 20 minutes later that he
realized he had broken his hand and on
top of that he didn't even tell anyone
at first puts everything upside down for
arch and he's trying to help everyone
but he just feels like he can't do
anything
blake lively found herself thrust into
the role of an action star on the set of
the 2020 action film the rhythm section
while filming an action scene with her
co-star jude law lively shattered her
right hand which caused production to be
paused for half a year i was lunging
towards jude law with my fake rubber
knife and my hand collided with his
elbow and i broke some things dislocated
some things and severed a ligament it
was pretty intense but that's why you
guys have to see this movie out of sheer
guilt but i did get my right hand for
this movie people say that they don't
need it heartthrob nick jonas may have
been having a good time with his
brothers joe and kevin while filming the
television special olympic dreams
featuring the jonas brothers but the
party turned sour after one incident
jonas ended up cracking his rib in a
bicycling accident while filming after
which he was hospitalized but jonas
wouldn't let the injury ruin his plans
as he still went on to finish the
special continue his time on the voice
and host the 2021 billboard music awards
i'm feeling a lot more optimistic lately
zac efron injured his wrist while
filming a highly complicated revolving
set piece on the set of high school
musical 3 senior year while shooting the
scream scene efron admitted that he fell
hard multiple times which resulted in
his injury regardless of the injury
ephron still has some fond memories
while filming the memorable scene feel
the song coming on
johnny depp is no stranger to filming
big tentpole action flicks and while
filming disney's 2013 reboot of the lone
ranger depp had a close call while on
horseback depp was thrown from the horse
and was nearly trampled by the animal
while depp didn't suffer any serious
injuries the experience was still
terrifying it was a strange moment
because it wasn't like one of those
adrenaline-filled moments where you're
flipping out and panicking and stuff
like that stay back guys apart from the
medicine yeah let's see
isla fisher nearly drowned while filming
her character's introduction in the 2014
action thriller now you see me the scene
entailed fisher being in a tank full of
water in handcuffs which were supposed
to be magnetic so fischer could escape
quickly without issues unfortunately the
chain around fischer's ankles was not
able to be broken and was stuck
underneath a slot in the tank i was very
scared i was banging and saying set me
free but everyone just thought i was
doing fabulous acting they thought i was
being meryl streep in the tank actually
i was drowning kate winslet nearly
drowned while filming james cameron's
mega blockbuster titanic while filming
winslet was wearing a heavy coat that
got snagged on a gate leading her to be
briefly submerged in water
this led winslet to have to shimmy out
of her coat and she was breathless by
the time she escaped cameron didn't seem
too worried as he made winslet film the
scene again
charlize theron is no stranger to
headlining action picks while filming
the sci-fi action pick eon flux theron
was performing a series of back flips
before eventually landing on her neck
and herniating a disc near her spine
that injury scared me i was almost
paralyzed this injury led theron to be
more cautious on the set of her later
action flicks such as mad max fury road
and the old guard
while filming the acclaimed survival
drama castaway star tom hanks got a
small cut on his leg on set which
initially he believed was no big deal
after flying home after rapping his leg
started swelling up which caused him to
visit the doctor where he learned he had
a staph infection that was extremely
close to giving him blood poisoning the
infection was so bad that it could have
been fatal for hanks if he waited any
longer to have it looked at that movie
was literally about about physical
action priyanka chopra jonas had always
felt safe on the set of her abc series
quantico and praised the show's
producers for being very aware of just
how physically demanding the show was so
chopra did feel a bit more prepared for
when she received a concussion while
filming it was raining and the roads
were wet and i was in rubber boots and
we were running out of time i wasn't
warned of the conditions that were
outside before we went and me and my
colleague both of us fell and we were
both rushed to the er chopra was done
resting after a mere three days and was
eager to return to set
while halle berry is no stranger to
action roles there's been more than a
few times where she's suffered injuries
on the set of her films barry got
knocked out while filming the thriller
the call broke her foot on the set of
cloud atlas broke her arm while shooting
gothica injured her eye on the set of
die another day and suffered a head
injury during the production of catwoman
and if you hurt so what you just come
back and you do it again tomorrow
there's no room for complaining
from broken bones to concussions and
infections these stars definitely
suffered through some pain in order to
give audiences their favorite shows and
movies even hugh jackman suffered an
onset injury after stabbing his upper
thigh with his wolverine claws on set of
x-men 2. thanks for watching
you